what what's the Hallmark of a great
script how do you know you you want to
choose that one over for thousands of or
hundreds of others that you look at what
um personal a personal and usually I
don't read other people's scripts I
usually develop something or I have
something in mind that I work with a
friend but for example when taxi driver
was given to me to read by Brian De
Palma I hadn't done main streets yet and
so but he said you'd be great for this
and automatically I mean it had to be an
emotional connection to the material and
to the characters the obsessive mess of
Travis Bickel the sense of being The
Outsider and not being the dispossessed
that's how I you know we felt that way I
mean myself and I I could speak for De
Niro to a certain extent because we
didn't articulate it that way I can't
really say oh you know we're Outsiders
we were trying to get in we're trying to
stay in Hollywood but certainly taxi
driver when you got that so this this
one has to be made and we just knew it
because actually the first versatility I
read was Notes from Underground that was
Taxi Driver really
so you know hey I feel like that that's
me you know that sort of thing so you
really you really identify with